how would you describe the quantum realm
okay this mean you can't get it wrong
say this is what you think it's not
subjective it's not sure it's actually a
very objective yes how do you describe
it she might say it's like cotton candy
the quantum road and that would be wrong
you can't know it's it opinion might be
like inside steel it's hard okay as
everything happening at once it's
profound and incorrect but we'll take it
quantum realm is the depends now we're
talking quantum realms in terms of
realms there are is an astral plane
if the astral plane can astral glide
into the quantum realm then it feels a
lot better it's like an area that's of
quantum very that's why I might get
shrunk to kind of the bleed into that
sort of can use and lastly we don't know
the name of the next Avengers you
believe in the untitled Avengers for
what should it be called no Avengers
this is what happened next
it should be called The Long Goodbye
so Avengers and you have the nose and
you have a quote and you have Dino
saying I never let you have in
parentheses in action which is everybody
is Charlie what a surprise all the
Avengers talking about the quantum realm
and the title for Avengers 4 before we
even knew what was going on with ant-man
the wasp so we gonna break this down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's a new infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video because we're
talking about quantum realm stuff in the
day that I'm posting this video is the
week that it's being released in the UK
just careful for spoilers if you have
not seen ant-man in the wasps because we
need to talk about the end of that movie
so here we go the big thing here is that
there are a couple actors here that
definitely have no idea what's going on
with the quantum realm and some of them
very definitely do know inter trying to
tiptoe around spoilers Chris Pratt
especially thankfully though Mark
Ruffalo and Tom Hall and spoiler Bros
are both in the interview the stuff that
Mark Ruffalo says is a little bit more
important than what Tom Holland says
because he's being very sincere with his
answers he's not trying to give away
fake word salad answers like Chris Pratt
like Chris Pratt is just like talking
around the astral plane Astroglide he's
just trying to spit out answers because
he definitely knows that the quantum
realm was part of the scripts that he
was given because remember when this
interview was conducted
they had already shot all of Avengers
for me the star-lord probably comes back
for some quantum realm action the beauty
of the way that Marvel and the Russos
kept everything secret on said was by
barely giving anyone any pages that they
needed handing out fake scripts and if
actors weren't involved in scenes they
just wouldn't give them those pages so
the fact that Chris Pratt seems like he
knows what's going on with the quantum
realm and has to like not give away
spoilers and just spit out funny answers
means he has scenes with characters that
involve the quantum realm otherwise his
answers would have been a little bit
more like Drax and Mantis here like they
just seem like they don't know what's
going on so they probably didn't have
any scenes where people are directly
mentioning or referring to quantum realm
stuff so you can kind of tell which
actors were in which types of scenes
based on their level of comfort in
situations like this with a few
exceptions like the more experienced
actors like Don Cheadle Mark Ruffalo
Benedict Cumberbatch they're a little
bit better at handling questions like
this without giving away big spoilers so
odds are that Warmachine doesn't have a
lot of quantum realm based scenes but
you can bet the Doctor Strange does you
can bet that the Hulk does because of
all those set picks that we've seen
where they're all walking around with
those risk devices on with Ant Man very
clearly tied to quantum energy from the
end of ant-man and the wasp but probably
the most important thing that said
during this interview is when he asked
what Mark Ruffalo thinks the quantum
realm is and he describes it as
everything happening at once and even
though the interviewer probably had not
seen Ant Man and the wasp and hadn't
really thought of it in that way it was
and thinking about the multiverse in
multiple different realities we know
because of ant-man and the wasp that the
quantum realm exists in multiple
realities like the ghost phases through
multiple different realities
simultaneously that's why her molecules
are being ripped apart Mark Ruffalo's
saying that that place is everything
happening at once means he has scenes
that involve the quantum realm quantum
energy and confirms multiple realities
but it's really confirmation of plot
devices not so much the actual plot
itself like what do they do with the
quantum energy how do they use that to
save the universe that a lot of theories
about that but Tom Holland what he does
there is he actually confuses a bit of
the plot of the Doctor Strange movie
because obviously that movie happened a
while ago everybody's seen it so he
understands that dr. strange traveled
through multiple realities but if he
couldn't hear because it says it really
softly he says I thought that that was
your realm mistakenly confusing the
quantum realm with all the different
dimensions the Doctor Strange travelled
through at the beginning of his movie
his heart rate is getting dangerously
high
the thing about that is is that you
actually spot the quantum realm when
he's on that journey that the ancient
one sends him on so yes he has been
through the quantum realm it was a bit
of an easter egg about the connectedness
of the Marvel Universe in how the
quantum realm was basically a different
dimension because Doctor Strange was
essentially setting up what we know is
the multiverse part of the beauty the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the way
that it plays towards the fans and
towards a broader audience is that they
start out with like really small ideas
like hey what if dr. strange traveled
through multiple realities then once we
know that exists they use it as a much
bigger plot device in one of the big
Avengers films to blow our minds like oh
wow wouldn't it be cool to see other
versions of these characters like if you
ever read the secret war storyline a
couple years ago you get to see many
many different versions of all the
characters from Marvel Comics history
imagine Avengers 4 does a movie version
of that where you just get to see a
couple different versions of the
characters as they travel or look at
different realities we don't know
exactly how the movies gonna invoke
these other realities if they're just
gonna be looking at them using those
wristbands or if they'll be physically
traveling between them but I do like
mbaku comment that Avengers 4 should be
called quantum infinity now it doesn't
roll off the tongue but it just lets you
know that mbaku has a pretty good idea
that the quantum realm is a big plot
device during Avengers 4 some of the
Black Panther characters are probably
going to be involved in that and
obviously there's all these questions
about what's going on but shuri during
Avengers 4 because she's such an
important character from a scientific
perspective but because Black Panther
has died she's also now the heir to the
throne so arguably she'll be the queen
when Avengers 4 picks up but not to be
outdone Mark Ruffalo very sincere says
that it should be called The Long
Goodbye now this is him not trying to
tiptoe around spoilers but he's not
referencing the classic film The Long
Goodbye with Philip Marlowe it has
nothing to do with the actual plot of
that he's talking more about the meta
aspect of the characters in the actors
in real life saying goodbye to each
other
because without say like Secret Wars in
like five or six years whatever they
eventually get to that these characters
aren't going to be in a lot of films
together anymore so this is gonna be
like the last big ride with the phase
one classic Avengers teaming up together
because remember there been a whole
bunch of articles about the Russos and
why
they killed the characters that they
killed who survived there was a reason
for it is because they wanted all the og
Avengers from that first film to survive
to fight Thanos with the help of Captain
Marvel who will be coming in so there
was no big conspiracy it's like they
just wanted to kill off all the new
characters so that the og Avengers could
close their ten-year arc I just posted
that deleted scene with Ironman and why
his arc is so important for these 10
years worth of Marvel films like it
serves as the backbone for a lot of this
but it's also about the og Avengers
going back to that first film I'll link
the Tom Holland quantum realm interview
at the end of this to because he did an
interview where he gave away a whole
bunch of quantum realm stuff but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Nick tubby please email me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that
Ironman deleted scene and click here to
listen to Tom Holland give away a whole
bunch of stuff about the quantum realm
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]